the girag an experience we have
definitely hilar for his size his weight
most accomplished phenomenal all the
great what this guy did with his size
against opponents if people look like
not no way and yes it is a way yeah
indefinitely as you going heavier I have
my brother Hagin which was an amazing
fighter too
and evidently for me my time with
Hickson it's like you have the era of
Hickson you know a lot of believable
fighters but yo you in the wrong decade
take something and now could be you but
he was right there right you could have
been numbered you were number two on the
Hicks and you could have been number one
other anybody in the amazing thing you
feel like a chameleon and again he can
kind of make any game you train of him
he can pretend to be you fighting me or
anybody
it's amazing that aspect special did a
teaching process what was so good about
him he used to go to our school have 30
of the best guys all high belts and he
tells you okay choose how you want to
start and he chooses a cow he's not
gonna get on he gets out and he gets you
in the position you ask him to start
with everyone I think the most the best
thing that he has on his game on my view
and should they understand that was his
defense hmm no way to get him it let
your mom take his back do whatever you
want you can't get him he used to start
like guys take his back with a rear
naked choke fully locked in black belts
go ahead start from here stuff in defend
get on it out and get you there yeah
crazy then messes your mind up like hey
wait a minute
yeah how can he get out and he gets me
he can get out you know mm-hmm and I
think the amazing thing was his
confidence and belief on that and makes
amazing well he was unusual on that he
was really into physical fitness as well
like yoga really in the yoga become
incredibly flexible and strong and
really in the breathing
he had a amazing control of his body as
well as the knowledge of jiu-jitsu man
he brought a lot of elements to yeah I
don't think people realize how important
it was before so I knew that no you did
not
he brought in the breathing I spent the
the janowska that makes you come closer
to the nature habitat yeah gymnastic of
naturals what we're talking about it's a
style of who invented that was the man
Orlando Kenny and it was a Brazilian
thing as well Magellan guy he's still
alive in his eighties and you look at
him like how can he do or still do that
well and the whole idea is move your
body like the animals right so bring
back to us the animal instinct that we
end up losing by the generations you see
some of that now with IDO portal and a
lot of these guys are training martial
artists and these movement like movement
classes and movement styles and a lot of
that is very similar to gymnastic
unnatural amazing but the biggest
difference I think was the concept that
he used the approach that he used wasn't
as just mechanical the way it is it was
something that sometimes on the exercise
you change the direction of your
movements it's not certain kata you have
to do one two three four no he goes one
two jump before ten go back to six you
flow mm-hmm in Hickson brother into Jiu
Jitsu and I remember trained he goes hey
get there
keep keep moving keep moving don't stop
moving keep keep the flow off the
technique you're gonna get it
and he brought that movement into the
sheets which for me made a huge
difference in the way I fight how did
you fight before that we learned the
technique we do the drills and it's more
like you pause and wait for somebody to
pause in this position when he came in
understand that is you learn how to
start guiding people to where you want
them to go mmm
I'm training whew I want you to go to my
left there's no other way for it to go
to my right I learned how to mod my
binding away the only direct
you will have to go he's on my left I
know that but you don't brah
there we go I one step ahead then when
you go to my left you're gonna put your
left hand on the ground start off your
right hand I know that too then I'm two
steps ahead of you I mean when you're
trying to defend something you're ready
two steps behind because the defense is
our shorter than the offense you stretch
your arm for me to get your arm I have
to put my hands and swing my line for
you just bring one back right it's
always short it's quicker that's why
when you have one or two steps ahead you
don't have the time to defend well
you're blocking off the difference I'm
already too far ahead for it to defend
right and that's what I learned with
those movements that he brought into
jiu-jitsu mmm you start learning how to
guide and mold yourself to make you go
to that direction who was a challenge to
him in the early days because there was
a lot of great guys right we have a lot
of great guys and it's funny sometimes I
see you go to the internet and see some
of the fights and you notice that a lot
of guys they we can kind of hang out for
1 to 5 minutes after 5 minutes and great
athletes they just done right because of
that movement he keep going constantly
keep that rhythm people were not able to
keep up with him right and he's not
lifting weights and a bodybuilder no
he's and we learned how important for
human needs to be in contact with nature
would you imagine yourself not going for
hiking some days in the morning I mean
we need that we need that energy yeah we
need to walk without shoes we need to be
near the mountains the water mmm that's
something that maker is healthy and
stronger and that's why you see we used
to go a lot up in the mountains and
waterfalls and out of this city to
trying to get that in a healthy animal
instinct that we had yeah we're there
listen to the birds listen to in the
middle or maybe son coyote there are
people that on the city they've gone the
mountains they're gonna get eaten eaten
by a mountain life it's not even here
the mountain life but if you walk in the
heart off and you understand that you
develop and still have that oh I heard
something there mmm
we're losing more of that
as usual we're trying to bring people
into that environment which is something
they make you better off regardless be
more aware of yourself
exactly